la énième relance de l'interminable
affaire grégory cette fois ce sont les
parents de l'enfant assassiné qui porte
plainte contre les dysfonctionnements de
la justice christine villemin notamment
dont l'innocence n'avait été reconnu
qu'après huit ans de procédure dominique
verdeilhan alain poirier des auditions
les villemin on en subit beaucoup depuis
octobre 84 ce jour de joints 94 il était
devant les sénateurs et déjà christine
et jean marie faisait le procès de la
justice vous voudrions dire que les
victimes sont en droit d'attendre de la
justice procureur ou magistrat
instructeur
ce que nous n'avons pas connu le respect
de leur douleur une écoute et réconfort
dix-huit ans après la mort du petit
grégory ses parents attaque l'état et le
juge lambert en personne ils réclament
près de 200000 euros de dédommagement
autopsie incomplet perte de pièces à
conviction annulations de procédure les
avocats des villemin énumère les charges
contre le juge à l'audience cet après
midi pascal le fur le procureur
reconnaît des dysfonctionnements des
malfaçons
mais pour christine et jean-marie la
page n'est pas encore tournée 18 ans se
sont écoulés il essaye de se
reconstruire
ce qui n'est pas évident d'une part
compte tenu du fait qu'un enfant a été
assassiné et d'autre part compte tenu du
calvaire judiciaire que madame villemin
a dû endurer durant deux heures ce fut
d'abord le procès du juge lambert et
pour son avocat c'était avant tout un
procès d'intention vouloir tout ciblé
sur le juge lambert en disant c'est lui
qui est responsable de tout c'est
quelque chose qui est absolument
inacceptable pour lui il ne peut pas
l'accepter
depuis sa mutation à 87 il est juge de
l'expropriation à bourg-en-bresse
régulièrement il écrit un livre pour ses
supérieurs directs
il n'y a rien à redire le petit juge
a de bonnes notes